I am from a to borrow a lot of the
television in London with the Obama
administration's improve the state of
the world in 2009 I guess my work today
is at the junction that things and only
good as well the world has the thickness
before and the world is nothing but
expectation on high the basically the
prices all the troubles around the world
it's a lot for any administration let
alone for a new President Obama but
there is only one head which is human
hope which is not high these days but we
can look forward many crises could be
challenging economic one rewards
problems in the Middle East I guess more
or less we can manage these crises with
the Obama administration it could make
good and show some slight improvement in
order not to put high hopes because in
four years that's too short even that
start resolving even the basics of nurse
issues